what is so interesting to you about
bitcoin and cryptocurrencies like why
there's so much stuff that you do that i
find fascinating everything from what i
would consider like traditional uh
research just around human decision
making behavioral economics and that
stuff to even more of the like what some
people consider the more controversial
stuff and viewing hey we live in this
mad crazy insane world but
cryptocurrencies like why is that the
thing that now you're so interested in i
can i can sort of look at the crypto
space wearing a number of different hats
so one hat is just
as a behavioral scientist
what's going on with crypto it's an
exciting movement it's also
psychologically really confusing and
there's a lot of aspects of crypto that
are extremely counter-intuitive
like how do people think about value and
networks and security and
decentralization and
how do these protocols actually work
what's the kind of underlying game
theory of how do you get you know
consensus mechanisms that are
resistant to attack so there's kind of
the like psychology of of how people
understand crypto
another hat is just as an individual
investor
how do you face the very very steep
learning curve of trying to understand
what what the hell is this industry how
does it function
how do you distinguish
you know a good solid project from a
shitty meme coin
how do you kind of uh
work your way into the industry without
you know getting wrecked and losing
everything
and then
a third hat is just at a kind of social
and political and cultural level
what's going on with crypto how does it
challenge traditional
um finance and vested interests and what
are the full kind of cultural and
political implications so all three of
those um
are absolutely fascinating to me
and i love getting kind of red pilled by
new
you know human phenomena and i think
crypto
no matter what you think of it
as
um a movement or as a sort of investment
uh domain
is absolutely fascinating if you have
any interest in human nature or
psychology so let's start with the third
one first uh this idea of challenging
the establishment challenging the
incumbents whether they're just
financial firms uh or something much
bigger how do you think about uh
evaluating the current new technologies
that we have versus that like old legacy
world the funny thing about the old
legacy world the way that fiat currency
works the way that banking works is it's
really hard to understand the legacy
world
until you understand crypto
right because you just take the legacy
finance world for granted you just kind
of think that's the state of nature
obviously that's how capitalism and
finance and money and and pensions
should work because there's no contrast
there's no alternative once you get a
serious contrast a sort of alternative
system then you can start to kind of
pick apart the legacy system and
understand
oh my gosh like here's banking here's
why wall street and banking have certain
kinds of lobbying here's why they have
certain kinds of political influence and
um
here's why it's oppressive and kind of
constraining to people
so i kind of felt like crypto blew my
mind about that because
you know i've like worked in an
economics department for four years at
university college london
surrounded by people who do behavioral
economics work
and in a way they
kind of know less
about the existing finance system than
even
kind of crypto newbies who have just
read a little bit like you know the
bitcoin standard or watched your show
for
you know a few hours and so when you
think about that uh maybe difference in
education is it because they are
incentivized not to understand so if
you're sitting at an academic
institution whether you're sitting in an
elected official position or in an
appointed position uh let's just call
them kind of the academics and theorists
if you will rather than the market
participants is it a you're
disincentivized from learning is it you
don't need to so you're almost
complacent or
do you actually understand and uh you're
better off not letting on the fact that
you understand because that would then
the game would be up if you will i think
it's mostly just you're surrounded by uh
groupthink you're surrounded by
like-minded people who've all taken the
same
you know
200 level macro economics courses that
say this is how money should work this
is how you should manipulate the money
supply
in order to deal with financial crises
or promote growth or manage unemployment
and if you get you know a's in
macroeconomics and then you become like
a finance person or a banker or an
economist you figure
well i got the seal of approval from
traditional econ i must know what
i'm talking about and everybody around
me thinks the same way
so
stepping outside of that is very
difficult because you're you're subject
to immense
um professional pressures to kind of
conform to that world view
if you start talking about alternatives
you know everybody you know thinks
you're kind of crazy and also you've got
heavy professional disincentives not to
make noise about that because
you know you
it'll limit your career options for
example if you're an economist who wants
to like advise governments about things
you kind of have to buy into like
the imf fiat world view about these
things
when you start to look at the behavioral
economics of all of this uh there's a
lot of talk of game theory right of of
kind of bitcoin is inevitable uh people
have to adopt it at some point and i
think when people were saying that in
2010 2011 2012 that was like a a pipe
dream and even the people that were
involved in were like yeah i mean we
kind of believed it but you know that
was kind of crazy idea
now it seems to be playing out we've got
individuals in now we've got financial
institutions we're starting to see some
public corporations we have one nation
state that's made illegal tender and
really started to kind of uh embrace it
is this
using history as like a guide
of course this was going to happen of
course this is like the natural
progression of something or are you
surprised by this given kind of the the
mental models and experience that you
have in some of these disciplines
the game theory here is really
complicated so there's kind of one level
of game theory which is at the protocol
or consensus level of how do you keep
any given protocol like you know bitcoin
or ethereum or cardano resistant to
specific kinds of attacks
but then there's a larger kind of
political game theory which is
how do you get enough
buy-in from existing power structures
including regulators and nation-states
so that they can't mess it up
so that
for example enough politicians are
personally invested in bitcoin or have
family wealth in bitcoin that
they no longer have the personal or
political incentives to attack it really
hard
as far as i can tell there's a lot more
game theory applied to kind of how do we
keep you know bitcoin safe from a 51
attack
ban there is game theory applied to that
larger political issue
um or the issue of like
the sort of intergenerational thing of
how do you convince rich boomers to
actually invest in crypto rather than
just young people who don't have any
money or middle-aged you know guys like
me who have like a little bit of money
and a little bit of understanding
so
when you're doing game theory and you're
thinking
how do we make this
um crypto protocol resistant to attack
the attacks can come from many many
levels it could be
political regulation
it could be a kind of cultural level
attack like if crypto somehow got
associated with certain
um
taboo beliefs
right if if it was smeared by
association with certain
um
unacceptable cultural associations
then nobody would want to own crypto
because the social cost would be too
high
so when you're thinking about the game
theory you have to be
very inclusive in thinking
what are all the possible vectors of
attack that could mess up the crypto and
just